if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to two hundred
dollars off and two free pillows at
helix sleep.com
pacman
so many of you will remember that i've
been giving good news about declining
covet cases on the show
uh in the united states dating back to
really the first few days of september
um i've also been saying since late
october that decline is starting to slow
down
and then we got to well the cases are
now flat they're no longer declining we
don't know if this is an inflection
point and cases will start going back up
or if they'll stay flat or if they'll
continue on down we don't know what will
happen heading into winter
we now have a modest but clear trend
which is that cases in the united states
are going back up
and in fact they've been on the upswing
since roughly halloween so close to a
couple of weeks and cases are now up in
the united states
just shy of about 10 percent per day we
had gotten down to
000 cases a day which is crazy to think
that wow what we had a huge decline down
to 71 000 cases a day
that is now back up to 77 000 cases a
day and this is really really
not good
now
if we were at the point where cases no
longer meant deaths
either because
enough vaccination has taken place where
most folks are protected against serious
illness and death or
because of a less deadly strain that has
evolved this wouldn't be as bad but
those things haven't happened yet
and so far deaths have been following
cases by about three to four weeks and
just as we saw cases stop their decline
three to four weeks ago
deaths are now flat
deaths are no longer declining they're
stuck at about 1100 coveted deaths per
day in the united states so there is
every possibility that we are at the
beginning
of a new spike and a potentially very
ugly winter now maybe not
maybe not we don't really know yet but
the case increase has started and the
death decline has stopped
now often as we've seen throughout the
pandemic what happens in the united
states follows what happens in other
parts of the world part of the reason
for that is that many of the
spikes are caused by variants which we
first observe in other parts of the
world like europe so far
the global numbers are not looking
particularly auspicious for the united
states over the next three months cases
around the world are up even more than
in the united states globally cases had
bottomed
back um they'd bottomed out at 403 000
cases a day
globally cases are now up to 472 000
cases a day so while in the u.s cases
are up 9 or 10 globally cases are up
about 17 that's not a great signal
for what is to come here
as far as global deaths
those are slightly up global deaths had
bottomed out around 6 600 a day
deaths are now back up to 7 100 a day
around the world that's an increase of
about six or seven percent
so if there is any good news to point to
and even this you'll see why it's not
even that great
we can point to hey vaccinations every
day are now climbing in the united
states they're not incredible numbers
looking at the graph on the screen if
you're watching today you might see that
daily vaccinations really bottomed out
in mid-july and then as delta surged and
discussion of delta surged vaccinations
also started to increase in late july we
were down to about 550 000 doses a day
that has climbed and climbed almost
tripling and we're now doing over the
last week about 1.3 million doses per
day unfortunately and this is just
horrible
the not so good thing is that the
increased doses per day
are significantly driven by people who
already have two doses getting a third
dose so you're not vaccinating that many
new people if you ask the question how
many new people are getting vaccinated
each day
it might only be a couple hundred
thousand to maybe three hundred thousand
sadly i mean it's good that people are
getting third doses and more protection
but a huge portion of the daily doses
today are people getting a third dose
good for those people
not so good for the population at large
now that five to 11 year olds can start
to get vaccinated in the u.s we do
expect the number of kids with um one
dose in that age group to be at roughly
a million right now about a million kids
have already gotten vaccinated that's
good but the misinformation continues to
kill people we have a report from
colorado uh from cbs denver
which says that according to
a colorado icu nurse there are many
covet patients they're in the icu with
covid
they don't believe the virus is real
they believe the hospital made them sick
and in some cases they call the nurses
murderers so that's very bad
we will see what things look like by
thanksgiving i've started to get
questions from from some of you about
what is my thanksgiving plan from the
standpoint of medical from the
standpoint of covid i'm going to be
doing a testing thanksgiving so it's
going to be
maybe outdoor maybe indoor depending on
the weather
everybody will be tested and i've
interviewed everybody will be vaccinated
and tested when we interviewed vincent
racanello from columbia university and i
said to him sir
is this foolproof if people get a test
right as they're going in
is there any way you might be incubating
and contagious but negative and he
basically said if you're using the test
for a few hour gathering it's
essentially foolproof in the sense that
this was what he said
if you are incubating the virus
and you don't yet have symptoms
and you test negative
you're almost certainly not contagious
for the next few hours so what you
wouldn't want to do
because of this possibility that you've
been infected you're incubating but you
don't yet test positive don't use a test
as justification to hang out for a week
without doing any more testing because
then you might turn positive and turn
contagious but if you're doing a few
hour gathering vincent raccoon yellow
was confident
that if everybody has a negative test
everybody's going to be not contagious
at least for a few hours so that's my
plan for thanksgiving i'm curious to
hear about yours
you know i have not spoken much recently
on the podcast and the broadcast because
uh about the kyle rittenhouse trial
because we've been covering essentially
the full trial every day on facebook and
um youtube not on twitch because we're
banned from twitch for 30 days so i've
just been getting so much of it i
haven't commented but i do want to talk
about it a little bit today over the
last 24 hours the kyle rittenhouse case
in kenosha wisconsin it's the trial of
kyle rittenhouse who is accused of when
he was 17 last year um homicide against
two individuals that he killed as well
as miscellaneous other charges related
to guns and and other things
this is a trial where the defense has
now taken over the defense called kyle
rittenhouse to the stand as a witness
and the prosecution was able to
cross-examine kyle rittenhouse yesterday
this has now led to a call for a
mistrial by the defense so let's look at
one article about this and then we're
going to look at a video because the
judge flipped out yesterday this is
getting a lot of attention because it
has become quite wacky
the kyle written house case is now in
jeopardy as lawyers seek a mistrial
trial judge accuses prosecutor of
improper line of questioning
what has taken place is that the
defense has asked for a mistrial on two
bases
the first is that at the beginning of
his cross-examination of kyle
rittenhouse the prosecutor
um
sought to
ask kyle rittenhouse
about
not
making a comprehensive public statement
about what he believes happened
the judge felt that this was trying to
use written house's silence against him
which would be a violation of the fifth
amendment okay
that's one basis on which the defense
wants a mistrial the other basis on the
def on which the defense wants a
mistrial is that they say the prosecutor
um questioned written house about things
which the judge had already said should
not be brought up
this is a basic summary of the reasoning
for the defense's request for a mistrial
the judge is considering that request
the defense wants a mistrial with
prejudice meaning that that's it that
the case can't be restarted a new case
can't be restarted against kyle
rittenhouse that would be
wild if that took place
i also want to play for you video when
this was being discussed of the judge
sort of flipping out on the prosecutor
take a look at this in the questions
i ask the court to strongly admonish him
and the next time it happens i'll be
asking for a mistrial with prejudice
he's an experienced attorney and he
knows better
mr finger
first of all your honor this was the
subject of emotion i'm well aware of
that
and the court left the door open
for me not for you
well my understanding of you should have
come and asked
for uh for reconsideration you did on
the one motion and in fact i granted
your motion for a reconsideration that
was going on
i i'm not talking
excuse me i uh
i did i created we did not move
we have not filed any motions to
reconsider in this case that was their
motion for reconsideration which i
denied but
uh i said
i denied it or i indicated a bias
towards denial is what i did held it
open with a bias towards denial why
would you think that that made it okay
for you without any advance notice to
bring this matter before the jury
you are already you were i was
astonished
when you began your examination by
commenting on the defendant's post
arrest silence that's basic law it's
been basic law in this country
for 40 years 50 years i have no idea why
you would do something like that so as
many have noticed the judge seems to
only bring this level of energy against
the prosecution there have been a whole
bunch of questions raised about this
judge and listen if the judge is biased
there's going to be the possibility of
an appeal in theory although prosecution
appeals and jury verdicts are very very
tough um i want to just kind of give my
general take on this case at this point
in time because i'm getting a lot of
emails from people saying david you're
this is obviously self-defense david
even tyt now says it will self-defense i
don't know what tyt has said to be clear
i'm just saying people are telling me
that that's what tyt has said let me
make my position on this case very very
clear i believe that kyle rittenhouse's
self-defense from a legal perspective is
going to be valid enough plausible
enough in the immediate situation in
which he shot the two people that he
killed
uh that he will be found not guilty i
believe that it is a plausible
i believe it may be quite true
that he feared for his life in that
moment which is what is on trial
okay so i'm not saying any of this uh uh
you know he's obviously guilty it
obviously wasn't self-defense i think
that from a legal standpoint
self-defense is going to be valid enough
based on the facts that not guilty will
be the verdict there
i also
believe
that the entire context here is a
disgusting context he had no business
going to kenosha and being armed that
night
the totality of the incident is
nauseating and the fact that
if he's convicted he will be considered
a martyr by the right if he is
acquitted he will be made a hero by the
right for the fact that he was there
with a gun
defending himself
when the truth is that this case is
emblematic of everything wrong with
american culture around guns
masculinity
vigilante justice
etc etc
now you can break down each part and say
well okay
in general just for being a 17 year old
being familiar with guns is not
inherently wrong or immoral
um
in theory protecting property
while holding a gun it's not
i mean you know would we feel
differently as a viewer emailed me if
this was someone protecting a
black-owned business with a gun from kkk
looters or something like that
most progressives would probably say no
that it's okay that that's being done
and if you do this you certainly can
make the case that there's no particular
one smoking gun
but this is
a symptom
of toxic underlying conditions
gun culture vigilante culture etc
and
that is different than should he be
found guilty that's not a crime what i
just said so
let's not
misstate each other's beliefs about this
and for the people emailing me saying
david you're so wrong for saying that he
should be found guilty it's for the jury
to decide and i believe that the
evidence for the narrow circumstances at
issue in the case
self-defense is plausible
and that he will be found not guilty on
the homicides that's my belief send me
your thoughts you can find me on twitter
at deepakman
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you first
hand every helix mattress comes with a
10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200 off your order and
you'll get two super premium pillows for
free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video okay let's get into some
interesting twitter posts from this
morning i'm sorry reddit posts reddit
posts you can join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
reddit more than 33 000 of our viewers
and listeners are currently subscribed
to reddit few interesting posts that
caught my eye um homelander posted lying
about a vaccination status is way worse
than kneeling for the national anthem
let's watch all the right wingers that
canceled colin kaepernick call what
aaron rodgers did patriotic yeah i mean
listen um
if you obviously if you believe the
pandemic is real and you believe that
vaccines are something that prevents you
statistically from getting really sick
or dying from the virus
and all of that stuff if you understand
reality
you would you would have to agree with
the statement that what aaron rodgers
did claiming to be immunized when he's
not putting teammates at risk etc is
obviously far worse than when colin
kaepernick kneeled during the national
anthem the problem is that many of these
right-wingers and trumpians
live in an alternate reality where the
pandemic isn't real or at least it's not
serious and vaccines are bad and the
worst thing you can do
is something cultural like neil during
the national anthem so you and i agree
uh on this
but the folks that are living in this
alternate reality don't there was also
an interesting post asking who's winning
on the vaccine issue politically is it
democrats or is it republicans now the
people from reddit who voted in the poll
by about a sec afford a three to one
about 75 25 margin said that democrats
are winning on the vaccine issue
ideologically the problem with this
is that
the winning would be not dying from the
virus
and unfortunately
um there are people across the political
spectrum who are dying from the virus
because in part of the anti-vaccine
propaganda that's being spread now that
being said
earlier this week we looked at the
numbers the cumulative cova death rate
in trump counties is now about 50
percent higher than the cumulative
coveted death rate in biden counties
even within the biden counties it would
stand to reason since the republicans
are the most unvaccinated that even
within biden counties it's more
republicans dying than democrats so it
is becoming partisan and if you consider
dying from the virus losing as
increasingly republicans are
then that is a way in which democrats
are winning on the virus but
uh on vaccination rather but
we aren't going to get out of this in
any serious way until more people are on
board and until more people are
vaccinated and so unfortunately as a
country we've lost a lot we've lost a
lot and we can point fingers accurately
as we have been doing
but what i want to get to
is the end of the pandemic and remember
the end of the pandemic is likely to be
coveted becoming endemic and a certain
level of cases and deaths much like with
flu that are not going to go away at
least for years at least for years so um
who who's really winning i feel like
we've all lost a lot over the last year
and a half of this pandemic
one other post from the subreddit
um
a user is asking for medical advice
and says can someone reach out to joe
rogan and see if he would consult with
me about colonoscopies
hi i'm 23 and highly lactose intolerant
can someone ask joe rogan if it's too
early to start getting colonoscopies is
joe taking appointments i'd prefer his
expert view on my colon health thanks so
obviously this is a reference to the
fact that now we've heard that nfl
quarterback aaron rodgers took medical
advice from joe rogan
and um
enlightened centrist political
commentator tim poole
took covet advice from joe rogan listen
as i've said before i don't think
there's anything wrong with talking to
people you know about their experience
with the disease if you were diagnosed
with a form of cancer
it would be totally reasonable
to go talk to a doctor and to get a
second opinion
and do all of those things and if you
had a friend who had had or has that
type of cancer it's totally reasonable
to go and say hey
what were the side effects of the course
of treatment you chose
how did you feel how did this work what
was your doctor's recommendation that
that makes perfect sense um but when we
start taking
anecdotal advice
from non-medical professionals about
things where we have data things like
ivermectin and others that's when things
sort of seem to go off the rails so
listen talking to friends about their
experiences with the disease or
medication is totally reasonable but the
degree to which aaron rodgers seriously
said well i mean listen i took advice
from joe rogan on what to do starts to
get a little weird starts to get a
little cultish almost um
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit i have a story for you today
that is really two stories coming
together story one is the story of
dishonest fox news graphics and charts
story two
is about labor force
conspiracy theories which we've talked
about before and the graphic in question
here is one that fox news put up on the
screen yesterday to try to make joe
biden look bad which simply says the
american workforce
trump peak
164 million people working
biden last month
only 161 million people working making
the point
that there are 3.1 million fewer people
in the workforce
as of last month under joe biden
than at the peak
during donald trump's administration now
i hope that by now
people who have been watching the show
listening to the show for a while know
at least two reasons why this is so
deceptive but the labor force stuff is
really frequently used by the right to
attack democrats so i think it's
important to talk about all of it so
first of all
without knowing anything about how the
labor force participation rate or labor
force participation numbers are
quantified calculate without knowing
anything at all
you should be suspicious as soon as you
see
the trump peak compared
with last month
this is called cherry picking of data
the data for the trump peak is december
of 2019.
they picked that number
instead of the number at the end of
donald trump's presidency why well
because the labor force has grown since
donald trump left office if you compare
the end of trump's term
to right now you would have to say the
labor force has grown under joe biden so
they pick december of 2019. now to that
end
why has the labor force been all over
the place it's been because of the
pandemic and that's still not over so
even at the top level
a comparison over the last couple years
of uh the labor force participation is
of dubious value it's a unique it's a
different time in american history
because of the pandemic so yes fox news
is being really deceptive they're cherry
picking they're leaving out information
their viewers are mostly clueless they
see this and they say oh my god what a
disaster biden has been
but there's even more instructive stuff
here the labor participation rate in
general isn't a good indicator of how
the economy is doing and in fact in a
good economy
the labor participation rate
and the number of people out of the
labor force can go down sir what how is
that possible
this is how it's possible
the labor force participation rate is a
measure of an economy's active workforce
so it's when we talk about there's 161
million or 164 million people in the
labor force we are saying this is the
sum total
of all workers employed or seeking
employment remember the way it's
measured if you're unemployed but
looking for work you're in the labor
force if you stop looking for work
you're out of the labor force but if you
retire you're out of the workforce
if you're 20 and in college full-time
you're out of the workforce and you
reduce the labor participation rate so
think about that really think about it
if you have a bad economy
there are people who would love to
retire but they can't afford to so they
need a job so they get one the labor
participation rate has just gone up
but it's because the economy is bad that
someone who would like to be retired has
gotten a job
okay
if the economy is bad a college student
might have to drop out of school and get
a job to help their family so the
economy being bad
has increased the labor participation
rate by forcing a college student to go
and get a job that's not a good
statistic by itself to tell us how the
economy is doing or whether a president
is doing a good job if wages went up now
think about the opposite if wages went
up and the economy did well you would
see more people say great i can now
retire up labor participation rate goes
down but it's because the economy is
good
one last thing
and this is like a systemic thing about
these numbers the population of the
united states is increasing over time
it's very common that at any given time
the number of people working is at a
record high and the number of people not
working is also at a record high so
think about that for a second
in 2010
the population of the united states was
308 million in 2010 okay let's just make
the numbers really easy forget about the
fact that children aren't considered in
the rate just make it 50 50. 308 million
people so in 2010 you could have had 154
million people working and 154 million
people not working
we're ignoring kids and people not
counted so in 2010 you could say
breaking record number of people working
and you'd be right
and at the same time you could say
breaking record number of people not
working and you would be right
then we get to 2021. we now have 330
million people in the united states make
it 50 50. okay
we now have
we could have 165 million people working
that's a record
and 165 million people not working
that's a record too so i hope that this
shows how useless
these numbers can be
when the population keeps increasing in
the country anyway so don't fall for
this stuff don't fall for the stuff be
informed and we'll have the graphic if
you're just listening today we'll put
the graphic up on our instagram which
you can find at david pakman's show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
emily broad lieb who is a clinical
professor of law and faculty director
for harvard law school's food law and
policy clinic um it's so great having
you on today emily really appreciate it
thanks so much i'm so glad to be here so
i mean let's just start with a little
history many of us are familiar with
with food labels in general and also
expiration dates best buy sell buy etc
what's the sort of history of that when
did it start why did it start
so we see um kind of this modern
landscape of you know these labels on
most food products really taking shape
in the 70s
and at that time it was really um
consumers were pushing companies and
saying that they wanted to know about
the freshness of their products and so
you know if you think about where we
were at that time it was sort of
starting after like post world war ii
people are getting more
you know further away from where their
food is produced buying more things in
the grocery store and you know people
said if i'm not part of the farm and
getting it directly from a farm how will
i know how fresh it is right and that's
when we we saw a lot of activity in
terms of um voluntary use of these
labels on the part of companies now
there was also in that period of time in
like the 20 years preceding the 70s
there was a move away from most of the
things at the grocery store our
ingredients to
really like the food product right
something that that's manufactured and
scent that and
is that also part of why we started to
see those markings that like with a
banana by looking at it you can mostly
tell what is the status of this banana
whereas with some of these products it
might be less clear
yeah that's totally right so
you know and i think even today in you
know
fast forward to now where there's
labels on lots of products a lot of
states require them but it's primarily
on packaged foods because i think
there's a sense that um you know banana
an apple you know a food a food that you
can pick up and hold and that's sort of
in its raw form uh that people can
really make their own judgments about
how fresh it is and how spoiled how
close it is to being spoiled um and it's
really packaged foods that you see these
labels on because people don't really
know they they can't open it up in the
store and smell it and waste it
so um
there's best if used by
there's sell by
there's a straight-up expiration date
that sometimes is there
these things presumably mean different
things right
one would think actually that's one of
the biggest issues is that consumers
sort of look at them and think these
labels must be telling me different
things but in fact um
you know most there's no law that really
regulates what those different terms
mean there's no um
you know there's no law defining sell by
as compared to used by or expires on
right now
in fact there's no federal law
regulating date labels at all so the
federal government with the very small
exception of infant formula has not
required anything and then in the states
that have requirements they use them
very interchangeably and so i think
that's one of the places where we got
really interested because consumers are
misled like they they think that they're
you know that they're seeing two
different labels and that they mean
something different but there's not
there's not any evidence that that's the
case right so so i mean if i see
as the common man if i see
sell by it suggests to me it should be
sold by that date but it's still pretty
good for some period of time beyond that
best if used by says it it should to me
it should be consumed by that day but
you're saying it's not actually there's
not actually an infrastructure that
guarantees that that's what i'm being
told
yeah that's totally right and you know
as we talk about by how this can be
fixed i do think there is a piece of
drawing on what consumers think that
they're reading yeah and you know
reducing the number of labels and really
drawing on like what consumers already
are understanding but just making that
the case so that consumers aren't you
know aren't being confused about it
with something like um i mean when i
first really started thinking about the
value of some of these labels is when i
saw for example an expiration date on
salt
and you know when we think about salt
it's like salt's been around for
millions of years it's just sort of
naturally occurring what does it mean if
salt expires um
does that have any meaning at all why
does salt expire right i agree with your
same vinegar similarly it's already
turned vinegar now it is vinegar it's
not going into some other thing
bottled water you know and i think
people are trying to like deal with this
cognitive dissonance by making up some
reason that the label so i hear people
say a lot oh the label on bottled water
is like when the plastic is going to
leach into the water i mean that is
there's no that is not happening or if
it is the date is not the date of which
that happens um you know i think you're
right that there are a lot of food
products that um
it doesn't it doesn't seem
very clear why a label a date label
would be needed on them except that
consumers have just come to
expect them on so many products and you
know i've actually talked to people who
have said when i pick something up at
the store that doesn't have a date label
on it i'm not sure what to do
um so you know again i think um
uh in some of our early work we thought
well maybe we should just remove the
label on foods where it's really
meaningless
um and i think that gets a lot of uh we
got a lot of pushback from consumer
groups on that so we're really thinking
how can we take what we have and make it
work better and make it align better and
be less misleading um you know knowing
that in some cases we are where we are
and we can't kind of completely overhaul
the system
the um if we want to apply like a
corporate profit motive to this
one could imagine
you could have foods that are safe for
much longer than the dates say
but maybe the manufacturer is worried
there could be reputational damage
because it might not taste quite as good
or whatever the case may be how much of
that is a factor in these labels
yeah
i mean that is it's a really big factor
especially you know if you think about
where we are right now which is some
states require dates on certain foods
there's a quite a just you know huge
variation in what foods states require
labels on and then what you can do after
the label and so that leaves a lot up to
the manufacturer as far as like what
words to use the science or if there is
any science behind how they're setting
that date um and of course for companies
they want you to eat their food when
it's going to taste the best right so
more even more cynical version that
people say a lot is you know is it that
they just want you to throw it away and
buy more and i don't think there's
necessarily evidence of that but there
is evidence and companies would say this
outright that
you know they want to set a label when
their product they think will taste the
best and they want to leave some wiggle
room for the fact that you might not put
your yogurt in the refrigerator right
away and that you know so they're kind
of being conservative even in that date
that they're setting
when it comes to um
food waste you know we've talked for so
long on this program about you got a
portion of food that is just wasted on
the field so to speak it it already is
sort of like by the time it would get to
the supermarket it might not look so
good so you lose some there you lose
food due to spoilage and you lose food
due to expiration dates and a question
that's often asked is shouldn't that all
be donated somewhere and one of the
reasons that sometimes given for why
it's not is if you donate stuff to a
food pantry beyond the expiration date
one are you sending the message that
people who need to go to a food pantry
are deserving of expired food right and
sort of like the pr issue with that but
also the concern of if someone gets sick
and it's beyond an expiration date is
the donor potentially legally liable so
are those and are there other ways in
which this is actually preventing
dealing with an issue like hunger yeah
yeah i think you're spot on um
so
um i would say as far as the first point
this sort of stigma point about is this
bad food are we essentially saying like
we're going to give bad food to people
um you know that are that are accepting
donated food on that piece
what our approach has been is to say
um if you really standardize the labels
to have one label that's really clearly
about food the small handful of foods
that actually increase in risk after the
date then everyone can be clear in their
own households and then we wouldn't
donate those foods we're not we
shouldn't be donating anything that
actually is riskier after the date and
then if you have a separate standard
label that's really telling people for
all of these foods you can keep eating
it as long as it smells okay tastes okay
you know this is just totally an
estimate of freshness
and then i would say i mean those should
be able to be sold they should be able
to be donated people should feel free to
use them people should swap them
whatever it is and so i think you know
to me a law that says that they only can
be donated but not sold and would you
know wouldn't make sense because it
would increase that stigma
and i'll say one you know peer country
that's done a really nice job of this is
the uk where they have
used by is the standard label on food
that becomes riskier after the date
best before is the standard label on
food that is labeled just for freshness
and then they've done actual campaigns
with consumers they had one last earlier
this year that was um like look smell
taste don't waste and the whole campaign
was really to let people know if you see
best before labels on it there's no way
that there's no scientific way to make
those accurate and there's no risk after
the date it's really just about your
preference and your power and again and
then they make it very clear those could
be donated they can be sold at a
discount you can still eat them you can
still serve them no one's going to get
sick and so i think again there's
there's like a very clear roadmap for
how we could improve on this and and in
a way that makes it not just for um
you know for for donation and giveaway
but also for everyone to save dollars
um there's a whole other kind of
category of food labels
these include um certified organic
all natural
no preservatives no added sugar
whole grains only you know we can kind
of go down the list and and different
ones mean different things are any of
these other than organic actually
regulated terms in any way that have a
set meaning every time they are used
so
it's a hard question because there's
truly so many of those labels yeah are
as like what so does so to speak eco
labels like organic that really relate
to like the the way that they're grown
and produced in the environmental side
organic is the only one um there was
legislation passed around bioengineered
label which would be foods that are
genetically modified and be relabeled
that will also be regulated
on the health side
there are some that are that are
regulated for example if you want to say
that a food is healthy
right
or something but there are also a lot
that aren't that heavily regulated so on
that side it sort of depends on the
label um but i should say you know
uh
these a lot of those fall to the food
and drug administration to enforce and
like there's thousands and thousands of
products with thousands and thousands of
labels and i think um i think most
people in this space present party
included would say that you know there
might be labels on there that aren't
actually being enforced because fda just
doesn't have the capacity to get to all
of them and make sure that they're
at one point there was this heart
healthy label which many of us would be
familiar from oats quaker oats
but it was basically if i recall
correctly at least in its initial
version based on the amount of fat and
so you had
very strange products including at one
point i think it was like the equivalent
of some kind of fruit roll-up type candy
which
i think qualified for the label based on
its absence of fat but it's not really
something that we would think i mean
it's a highly processed it's candy
essentially and so it was like this what
does this really mean right
right right now i think you're right and
i think this has been a critique of a
lot of those labels healthy
you know heart healthy low fat whatever
um
there are disqualifying levels of other
nutrients but sugar which really people
weren't as worried about right
you know in the 80s when a lot of these
labeling and early 90s so now you have
these bizarre outcomes where there's
like no disqualifying level of sugar for
all of these health-related claims um
you know i think this is something that
fda has been
supposedly working on hopefully we'll
you know get around to really updating
some of those labels because i think
they are really misleading for consumers
and i think today sugar is really one of
the most
concerning ingredients and products in
terms of just
the you know where we are as a country
so what is on sugar labeling like what
are some of the issues it seems i mean
some that come to me off the top of my
head is sometimes it will say no sugar
but it has various syrups which
are you know arguably not different than
sugar from a health standpoint
sometimes you will see
things like sweetened with beet sugar as
if that's
really different than cane sugar or
regular sugar when it's unclear there
really is a difference right i mean it
seems sort of like
the the gluten-free label on an apple
where it's like yes it's gluten-free but
is that really actionable and relevant
in any way
yes totally agree um yeah evaporated
cane
evaporated cane syrup is one you will
see and i still see it and i think you
know fda said it's not allowed again
they don't have the capacity to enforce
all of them so consumers pay the price
of that um you know i think that there's
both uh responsibility on the part of
the fda um and potentially on congress
to really beef up the the resources so
that those can be enforced um evaporated
cane syrup is literally sugar it is what
everyone would think of as sugar and yet
you know again it will say no sugar and
it will have that on a product and
yeah uh two other specific ones that i
want to ask about um so use organic is
actually a regulated term with a
specific meaning about about the the how
it's grown or whatever
um when it comes to all natural what is
important for people to understand about
whether all natural has any meaning
whatsoever
[Music]
great question um no one can answer that
question because there's no definition
um really from the food and drug
administration for all natural so
there's been a huge huge amount of
litigation um particularly in california
which has really nice um laws that are
very supportive towards consumers just a
lot of litigation around a product with
an all-natural claim
um you know and then plaintiffs
consumers saying
that they bought the product and then
realized afterwards there were certain
processing elements or it was ultra
processed or included you know gene
edited or you know genetically
engineered materials that people would
think don't seem natural and you know
there's there's i would say for now i
treat that claim as if like i just
ignore it completely i would say like
that mean that is meaningless at the
moment um and i think again there's
there's a big question mark as to
um if and when we will we will see the
fda come out with a real definition that
can give consumers a little more
confidence in that claim
last thing i want to ask about it i know
we're now getting like a couple levels
removed from from where we started
homeopathic products
herbal products some supplements etc
where they say
statements have not been evaluated by
the fda etc we've all seen that type of
thing
um what are the concerns and sort of
what is in that general space that
consumers should be aware of when
looking at those products
you know now you're a couple steps from
my
bellywick um
they're they're even you know i've
already said already that there's a lot
of claims on foods that um either fda
hasn't yet defined like natural they
don't really have a great definition um
or where there is a very clear
definition but they just don't have the
resources to enforce
once you get into supplements um you
know herbal things etc uh it's even more
so that way i mean a lot of people in
the food space will call that really the
wild west in terms of the
um
in terms of the the level of both laws
and
enforcement um so i think it's it's a
really difficult area i think there's a
lot of folks calling for more regulation
there and you know making sure both that
there's really two concerns one is when
you buy a supplement is what's in there
actually what it says it is right and
the second is are the claims about what
it can do for your health validated in
any way and i think on both ends of that
it's a really big question mark and it's
hard for the companies that are you know
trying to do it well and and trying to
do a good job because i think they would
probably like more enforcement so that
they you know they're they're that
people will have more trust in that
space yeah with without a doubt um emily
broadley is a clinical professor of law
and faculty director for harvard law
school's food law and policy clinic
really appreciate your time today
great talking to you thanks
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to
david
patreon.com
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow okay i have
a few sort of like short trumpy stories
to go over with you guys these these are
mostly comedic elements
but uh they're also just sad and
pathetic and more about just the sad sad
state of trumpism and republicans in the
united states which by the way they
could be in a sad state and still win in
2022 and in fact i think it's quite
plausible so first and foremost um you
guys know about donald trump i'm
guessing you also know about this guy
mike lindell we know him as mike pillow
he's the ceo of mypillow and mike
lindell has been one of the main
conspiracy delusionists um delusionists
or delusionalists i guess is the
question who has been
basically since the november 2020
election saying in december this thing
will be overturned by january 6th it
will be overturned by january 20th it
will be overturned it'll be march trump
will be back in office april it'll be by
the summer it'll be by the end of summer
the latest i think is that it'll be by
thanksgiving but clearly that is not
gonna happen and maybe he's forgotten
about that
this is so weird and bizarre
apparently mike pillow
has recorded
what they are describing as an exclusive
blockbuster interview with donald trump
and
trump's wearing a tuxedo in the
interview i don't know why i'm guessing
there's some explanation maybe this was
done at an event time who really knows
um and
pillow is promoting lindell is promoting
this interview
as
so earth-shattering that when he plays
it the week of thanksgiving
the american people are just going to
rise up and demand that donald trump
reinstating be reinstated
and uh i'm gonna look at just a preview
of this interview it's completely off
the rails take a look at this go back to
november 4th and we all live this
twilight zone
i always say like there was an old
saying you know if a tree falls in the
forest
and no one heard it did it really fall
well then the media tells us there is no
forest yeah i mean that's where it was i
love trump saying yeah as
as if he understands what pillow is
talking about here um let's continue
back in november and december and and
now you know we were yeah i know but we
were all living in this twilight zone
you were living there with us and
but then you had all the betrayals and
attacks on you that escalated to a whole
other level
and eric told me once that you said
right before you were going down that
escalator to make your famous
announcement can you imagine that you
said
well we're going to find out now who our
true friends are
and and i never forgot that he said that
to me
and you know it was everyone out there
since that time we've all been praying
for you for you to have strength and my
question is what does give you the
emotional strength
really a hard-hitting blockbuster
interview as you can imagine um so it's
sort of unclear what trump is even
really doing right now he may be you
know there's this idea that he's
preparing for some kind of
big
2022 participation of sorts in the
midterms
uh he's off twitter
we don't really know what it is that
he's doing other than publishing these
bizarre
statements so just to give you an idea
of what he's been up to an example
statement trump published to his website
the unselect committee of politically
ambitious hacks
continues to subpoena people wanting to
know about those protesting on january
6th the insurrection which took place
during the presidential election of
november 3rd so trump is now saying the
insurrection was the election that he
claims was stolen
there is so much proof but the fake news
media refuses to print it or show it in
any way read the arizona report look at
wisconsin pennsylvania georgia numerous
other states nothing's happening there
nothing's happening in those in those
states so trump with still insisting on
this stuff and at this point is it even
to raise money i don't know trump
i was going to say tweeting but
posting
blog posts where he says look at what
they found in georgia 74 counties in
georgia are missing ballot images
okay trump uh posting i i keep wanting
to say tweeting an article from the
daily signal claiming that 26 000 dead
people are still registered to vote in
michigan now remember guys we've talked
about this dead people voting thing
just because someone's registered and
died since being registered doesn't mean
they voted in michigan the dead people
voting thing has been widely widely
debunked um and then trump attacking liz
cheney with an approval rating at 19 in
wyoming people are wise to liz cheney
she is a threat to free and fair
elections which are the cornerstone of
our country because she caved so easily
on the crime of the century meaning
the fact that
joe biden actually won the election
um
this is sad
but i think we shouldn't underestimate
the reality
that there is still energy behind this
guy
and last week's election results
combined with whatever it is that trump
may have planned for the midterms could
very well lead
to republicans cleaning up in 2022
taking the house
taking the senate
winning more state governorships and
having almost democrats would have the
white house but having almost total
control of the country for at least a
period of a couple of years during which
they could do a ton a ton a ton of
damage
all right i i one of the
i guess we would call it a trend at this
point that we've seen for years as
donald trump makes holidays
tragedies
um and anniversaries somehow about
himself or about attacking his political
opponents donald trump uh it is veterans
day today it is veterans day today and
donald trump released a very short video
this morning
this is his tribute to veterans on
veterans day
now he sort of alludes to criticizing
biden by saying things are tough and
we're going to try to fix them he
doesn't name biden but of course it's
all alluding to it's just so bad under
joe biden right now
but also like just every aspect of this
is weird
the framing is from really far away from
trump like he looks almost 20 feet away
from the camera it's very strange but
the audio they don't even have a
microphone on trump
not even i guess caring enough about his
message to the troops which was
partially just a criticism of the
current state of affairs as trump sees
it they didn't even put a mic on trump
it's just whatever mike is on the camera
like down to the technical details it's
a very strange video let's take a listen
this veterans day i'd like to pay
tribute to all of those incredible
people and you are indeed incredible
people
who serve so well and so strong and so
powerfully
in the united states armed forces
we love you our nation respects you
the world respects you
and we will come back our country has
gone through a lot the last period of
time has been very very tough so this is
this is trump's way of criticizing biden
i just i hope there's no like what else
could he possibly mean there watching
what you had to watch
but our country will be back and we'll
be back stronger than ever
happy veterans day yeah
um donald trump has a very long history
of making tragedies
holidays
anniversaries about himself
on 9 11
you might remember that donald trump
called into a local tv station
and said hey you know now that the world
trade center towers fell
i have the tallest building in lower
manhattan remember this take a look you
have one of the landmark buildings down
in the financial district 40 wall street
uh did you have any damage or did you
know what's happened down there well it
was an amazing phone call i made 40 wall
street actually was the second tallest
building in downtown manhattan and it
was actually before the world trade
center was the tallest and then when
they built the world trade center it
became known as the second tallest and
now it's the tallest that was a nice one
right
um in 2011 donald trump claimed that he
predicted the 911 attacks he didn't
in 2013
he
memorialized 911
by sending his best wishes to the haters
and losers you might remember that one
and then of course many times donald
trump uh claimed to be at ground zero he
has said this on 9 11 anniversaries past
and just at other speeches
here is just one example of that soon
after i went down to ground zero with
men who worked for me
to try to help
in any little way that we could
we were not alone so that was a lie as
well donald trump was not at ground zero
any more than maybe he was in
an office that could generally be
considered to be in lower manhattan
around the time of 9 11. this should not
shock any of us this should not surprise
any of us
uh this is what donald trump does and
it's pathetic and it's humiliating and
embarrassing so okay not going to spend
a lot of time on it that's the latest
what the former president has been up to
uh over the last couple of days we have
a voicemail number that you can talk
call if you want to uh tell me anything
you know if you have any messages for me
you can call
219 to davidp
and tell me what's on your mind here's a
really really weird voicemail
um
i'm gonna play it because it's just kind
of funny and weird but take a listen
hey david do you believe in birds
you know i do believe in birds i've seen
birds i've seen the evidence with my own
eyes
i've spoken to ornithologists who are
confident that birds exist
i've had birds ravage my backyard garden
and i feel
very strongly that birds exist
in this
world we have a world
uh where birds are a part of it so
i don't know it's kind of a strange
question once i got a question about
whether i believe africa is real and i
do i believe africa is real as well
strange questions but glad to answer
them we have a tremendous bonus show for
you today
inflation
is at its highest level
since 1990
okay
we're going to keep talking about
inflation and part of that conversation
will continue today
portugal
a great country i love portugal portugal
has made a law
not about drugs we've talked about their
drug policy
that bans bosses from texting employees
after work
why and why now part of it has to do
with telework and work from home we will
discuss and lastly we now have seen you
know we talk about consequences for the
for the trump riots from january 6th
we now have seen the longest sentence
yet for any of the trump writers it was
given to scott farrell and uh feds want
an even stricter punishment for the guy
known as the q anon shaman imagine that
two years ago i didn't imagine we would
be talking about anybody that goes by
the q anon shaman but we are um feds are
asking for an even longer sentence for
the q anon shaman and we're going to
talk about how these cases are going how
strict are the sentences and more on
today's bonus show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com
uh you can use the coupon code better21
to get a discount off of our memberships
we will see you on the bonus show and
live coverage of the kyle rittenhouse
trial also continues today um on youtube
as well as on facebook we are 27 days
from being back on twitch banned for 30.
we'll be three down 27 to go so just
facebook and youtube today for the kyle
rittenhouse trial see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to two hundred
dollars off and two free pillows at
helix sleep dot com slash pacman